avant d'aller vous acheter un ipad avant
de vous acheter un iphone tout ce que
vous voulez il faut toujours se poser
une question c'est qu'est ce que je vais
en faire quels sont les usages c'est
vraiment tout le plus important parce
que je vais vous parler d'un ipad je
parle de l'ipad r de 2020 il est très
bien sa taille pas d'air de 2020 si vous
voulez un ipad vous serez absolument pas
déçu mais est-ce qu'il est fait pour
vous c'est vraiment la question à se
poser posez-vous donc tout de suite la
question de vos usages qu est ce que
vous allez faire cet ipad
et qu'est-ce que vous ne ferez pas
d'ailleurs prenez le temps mettez la
pause marquée le mont amba
prenez deux minutes s'il le faut vous
mettez la pause vous réfléchissez et
vous marrez quels sont vos usages à vous
en bas en commentaire et après on verra
s'ils peuvent effectivement coller à cet
ipad ou alors pas du tout moi je vais
être hyper transparence sur les usages
avec mon ipad et bien en fait mon ipad
je l'utilisé je suis tombé moi mon ipad
je l'utilisent quasiment tout le temps
pour du divertissement pas de
productivité
je ne fais pas de photo avec je
n'utilise pas particulièrement le style
est alors oui effectivement quand je le
teste jeu l'utilisent mais en règle
générale c'est pas trop dans mes usages
ça dépendra bien évidemment de tout un
chacun mais comme moi je fais de la
vidéo je fais tout le temps du montage
sur mon macbook pro toute la journée je
gère tous les e-mails son macbook pro et
quand je ne suis pas seulement macbook
pro je suis sur mon iphone
maintenant dans cette gamme d' ipad
cette année en tout cas on veut
distinguer trois produits on à l'ipad
plus d'entrée de gamme dont je vous
parlerai dans quelques jours dont vous
invite à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas comme ça on parlera des
ipad et de plein d'autres produits vous
allez voir on s'amuse bien en forme
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge en bas
âge sur des matches comme ça vous serez
notifié dès qu une prochaine vidéo
arrivera donc vous avez cet ipad qui
coûte un peu moins cher qui est un des
moins chères en tout cas et qui a
vraiment bien vous rend de grands
services et notamment sur tout l'aspect
multimédia et on en reparle dans
quelques jours vous avez ensuite l'ipad
r qui coûtent un peu plus cher tout de
suite on est à un peu moins de 700 euros
mais on a un très très très bon produit
et puis enfin pour ceux qui veulent le
maximum utiliser le maximum de
performance qui veulent deux caméras
l'arrière qui vole en laser qui veulent
promotion' avec un franchissement de 120
à 130 me pour les personnes qui veulent
le mieux aujourd'hui vous avez l'ipad
propose donc le choix entre trois ipad
alors quand on en sera question
nationale parade aussi ce qu'il y avait
les années antérieures pour acheter sur
dur conditionné de l'occasion ça peut
aussi valoir le coup donc toutes ces
questions doivent se poser donc on n'en
parlera plus tard pour
vous aide à choisir votre ipad mais
aujourd'hui par rapport à cet ipad est
repoussée vous vraiment la question de
vos usages
est ce que si c'est pour faire comme moi
regarder des films et des séries
est-ce que c'est l'ipad r qu'il vous
faut je pas convaincu entendons nous
bien l'ipad r c'est vraiment une très
belle bête on n'est pas ici dans un ipad
low cost on est vraiment dans un très
très bel ipad sont tous ipad r il est
vachement cool parce que si vous
connaissiez les précédentes générations
eh bien voyez qu elle même une vraie
différence vous n'avez plus le gros
bouton avec touch heidi en bas vous avez
des bords qui sont très très très très
faim un ipad qui est très bien profilée
avec vos boutons sur le côté ici la pape
qui se cachent pas juste là vous avez un
autre bouton ici en ce bouton là ils
écoulent justement je vous parle et au
tchad y est deux secondes
et bien ça c'est un capteur d'empreintes
digitales c'est punchy dit en fait hein
vous allez retrouver
c'est la marque déposée par apple qui
lui permet de venir le déverrouiller
très très très rapidement au plat je
pose mon doigt
paf et se déverrouille ça c'est vraiment
bien on a ensuite au dos et bien une
seule caméra de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 1.08 ok ça marche on a
des connectiques ici pour son magic qui
bordent on regarde ça dans quelques
instants vous avez également ici votre
petit emplacement pour venir poser
et bien si vous le souhaitez votre ipod
pencil de deuxième génération
vous avez haut parleurs stéréo un haut
parleur qui se situe sur le haut un
deuxième haut parleurs qui se situe sur
le banc ça m'a fait marrer l'autre soir
quand j'étais devant vont au lit et que
je démarre mon ipad je le prends je
voulais face à moi j ben qu'est ce qu'il
fait là me reconnais pas y reconnaît pas
mon visage parce qu'en fait je suis
habitué utilisé depuis quelques mois un
ipad propageant team ans prêté apple
fait du coup j'étais plus habitué à
tahiti en fait c'est très facile vous
allez hop poser votre doigt les
verrouille très rapidement très
facilement h alice est extrêmement
efficace c'est pas tout nouveau mais par
contre ce qui est nouveau c'est qu'apple
ait intégré ici sur son bouton au lieu
de la voir effectivement qu'un gros
boutons sur le banc c'est donc à la fois
plus jolie pratiques esthétiques
il ya un vrai gars là dessus puis
surtout il ya strictement aucun intérêt
que je me retrouve avec faith heidi là
dessus il faut bien démarqué les gammes
un ipad r mais pas on n'est pas trop il
ne sera jamais un ipad pro l'ipad r est
un produit qui se destinent au grand
public
on va donc pas m à l'intérieur de ce
produit qui est un super produit un lait
qui n'est pas le produit d'exception le
produit d'exception reste l'ipad pro et
malgré tout style pas d'air il est super
bien sûr tout
à peu près 200 euros d'écart avec l'ipad
proa première qu'on fit donc pas de trop
parce qu'on a quand même plusieurs
on se rapproche vraiment tout doucement
du prix de l'ipad trop n'ira pas sur des
usages aussi pointu qu'on peut avoir
avec un ipad pro on se destine plus à
monsieur madame tout le monde qui
veulent une très très belle tablette qui
vous emmènera très loin dans le futur
parce que oui si vous avez une tablette
qui marche vachement bien et surtout une
tablette qui est extrêmement performant
et qui est même plus performantes comme
avec pas de trop aujourd'hui en tout cas
tout de suite à un instant t en 2020 fin
2020 puisque vous avez la dernière puce
d'apple c'est la a14 bionique à l'ordre
ipad pro vous avez une puce de la
génération précédente parce que les pas
de pro a sorti plus tôt dans l'année
simplement l'année prochaine quand
l'ipad pro sortira en 2021
elle sera la plus puissante parce
qu'elle aura également la a14 blick
suivez un peu l'histoire moi ici le
poids ne m'a pas dérangé 4 158 g là où
j'ai trouvé un peu plus lourde c'est
parce que je viens utiliser mon magic
qui bordent avec un accessoire que je
trouve presque indispensable avec l'ipad
pro je trouve vraiment indispensable là
on commence à se poser vraiment la
question parce que l'accessoire est
vraiment superbe et a vraiment un sens
on en reparle dans quelques instants
et lorsque vous mettez les deux ans en
tout de suite c'est beaucoup plus long
maintenant parlons l'écran parce que
l'écran c'est aussi ce que vous avez
sous les yeux en permanence on a ici un
écran liquid retina 10,9 poussée de l'î
-p -é s2360 par mille 640 pixels à 264
pixels par pouce
il ya technologie true tonnes on a une
gamme de couleurs p3 en un revêtement
antireflet une luminosité maximale de
500 dit écoutez - l'écran je trouve
vraiment bien je trouve de bonnes
qualités bien calibré apple maîtrise
toujours très très bien sa copie au
niveau de ses écrans quel que soit
d'ailleurs les écrans et vous sortent
sur des trucs qui sont vraiment toujours
très très très bien maîtrisé est bien
ici une fois de plus apple a vraiment
bien bossé un écran que se trouve pas
fatiguant pour les yeux pour utiliser
aussi bien le soir dans le lit avec peu
de lumière ou carrément dans le noir
pour regarder films et séries ou aussi
bien la journée pour dire travail que ce
soit en intérieur ou en extérieur
les haut parleurs stéréo feront le
boulot parce qu'ici oui vous avez des
hauts parleurs stéréo et oui oui une
fois de plus ne vous trompez pas ici on
pourrait croire
regardez la veille titre ou la petite
roue là vous avez le même de l'autre
côté on pourrait se dire qu'on a quatre
haut parleurs comme ce qu'on a quelques
accrocs sauf qu'ici on n'est pas sur un
ipad pro on est sur un ipad r quelle est
la grosse différence ça va venir vous
apporter parce que même sur un ipad pro
et bien vous avez un signal stéréo qui
sort vous avez donc dû son gauche ici du
son
roy ici c'est la même chose sauf qu'ici
en ayant deux formes un des haut
parleurs en en ayant deux là et là au
lieu des 4 vous allez avoir un peu moins
de puissance sonore mais vous aurez
toujours une image stéréoscopique
donc ça va pas changer grand chose en
plus vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 pour me
reconnecter volet repose très facilement
et ça marche très bien dans l'écosystème
apple et toute l'expérience logiciel est
vraiment bien maîtrisé avec ipad ios 14
se passe très très rapidement au dessus
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le sujet
de cette vidéo mais ipad aux as 14
marche super bien pour tous vos usages
une fois de plus près dans ce logiciel
est très bien maîtrisée chez apple
tous fonctionnent ensemble au niveau de
l'écosystème si vous avez un iphone si
vous avez un mac book mac book pro imac
mac mini ce que vous voulez ça marche
merveilleusement bien et sein des très
gros point fort d'apple la compatibilité
entre tous vos appareils adecco système
complet et c'est une très grande force
de la marque
on pourrait se dire c'est dommage et
s'il n'y a pas de prise jack absolument
aucune
mais il faut vivre avec son temps on est
chez apple on en 2020 si vous voulez une
écoute au casque qui s'y faisait dans
l'écosystème apple il vous faut dr paul
dr paul pro un casque beats ou alors
n'importe quel casque sans fil fera très
bien la ferme donc le fait qu'ils aient
pas deux prises jack aujourd'hui ça me
paraît normal sur ce produit là en tout
cas en 2020 question stockage
moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est le fait
qu'on commence à 64 giga de stockage ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que cette
machine là si vous voulez vous
aujourd'hui vous allez lagarde et
minimum 5 ans grand minimum 5 ans en
cinq ans vous allez stocker beaucoup de
ça tout vos documents seront stockés en
priori dans le club mais pour tout ce
que vous allez stockées là dessus 64
giga de stockage sur cinq ans ça peut
être un petit peu moyen parce que oui si
votre tablette en 64e de stockage écoute
tout est noté là dessus elle coûte la
modique somme de 669 euros comme une
certaine somme et la version en 256 go
de stockage coûte 839 feront là donc 170
euros d'écart on prend le 64 giga de
stockage et le 256 go de stockage donc
j'imagine très probablement qu'ils n'ont
pas mis des versions 128 go de stockage
en configuration de base pour avoir un
ipad r en dessous des 700 euros autre
point connaître c'est la question de
l'autonomie on peut voir n'est pas qui a
duré 6 à peu près 10 heures en fonction
de vous
vos usages des logiciels que vous allez
faire tourner de suivre si vous
l'utilisez régulièrement long de la
journée une journée sans aucun problème
vouloir faire de soi et vous êtes
reparti le lendemain très facilement
vous leur charge et bien évidemment ici
en usb c'est grâce à un chargeur de 20
watts inclus mais pour moi là où apple a
été très fort cette année est venu
apporter d'autres usages aller plus loin
il s'agit pas de notamment au niveau de
l'ipad pro ça commence en tout cas qui
avait pas de trop c'est grâce au magic
qui bordent parce que ce magic qui
bordent vous permet effectivement dans
un premier temps de venir protéger votre
ipad c'est pas usage principal vous le
prenez vous le positionner bien comme il
faut c'est complètement magnetix à 2,5
mais alors effectivement ça vous le
protège c'est bien le côté pratique du
magic qui bordent c'est que vous avez
essayé de l'usbc pour venir recharger
ça changera un peu moins rapidement que
si vous utilisez votre charge standard
mais sa marge sera quand même plutôt pas
mal mais surtout ce sont tous les usages
de bureautique et productivité que vous
allez à bord avec et que vous permet de
faire ce magic qui borde alors ici le
magic qui bordent il est plus petit que
le magic qui porte les soirs les pas de
pros forcément les pas sur les mêmes
tailles de machines donc on aura des
touches à quelques endroits qui seront
un peu plus petit que ce qu'on a sur lot
magic qui bordent mais par contre ça
vous apporte d'autres usages et c'est
pour moi tout l'intérêt de ce match qui
bordent bureautique familiale prise de
notes en cours suivie de ses comptes
traitement de texte avec le magic qui
bordent vous pouvez faire beaucoup de
choses
le trackpad est aussi hyper agréable à
utiliser vous pouvez l'utiliser à un
doigt à deux doigts mais également à
trois doigts
c'est tout simplement génial et sans
même beaucoup plus loin votre ipad votre
ipad r il a un vrai sens aujourd'hui
parce que vous l'utilisez vraiment comme
un petit ordinateur qu'on la
productivité familiale alors pourquoi
poste vous êtes un commercial et vous
allez faire un reporting vous pouvez
également utiliser
c'était une des limites qu'on avait avec
les ipad avant c'était le fait de taper
sur son écran c'était pratique beaucoup
de personne l'utiliser mais je trouve qu
on n'utilisait pas l'ipad à 100 % ce qui
pouvait être utilisée grâce au magic qui
bordent cet ipad devient un petit
ordinateur
en plus ici vous avez comme je les dis
une puce extrêmement puissante
extrêmement performante peut donc faire
beaucoup de choses avec donc les usages
se démultiplient style pad transforme en
vol et c'est pour moi en tout cas une
très grosse nouveauté de cette année
2020 chez apple on regarde a eu plein il
ya eu plein de nouveautés le
renouvellement de produits
les grosses belle nouveauté pour moi
c'est un déchet apple et bien c'est ça
c'est le magic qui borde il y a eu
également une autre annonce qui était
très très cool c'est le fait qu'apple
fabriquent eux-mêmes maintenant leurs
puces pour leur ordinateur on a parlé
déjà quelques temps on en reparlera
d'ici quelques jours sur mon test du
macbook pro 13 pouces et du mac mini
très grosse nouveauté mais pour moi le
magic qui bordent en hardware pur et dur
en usage grand public
ça c'est une des nouveautés imparable
aux produits qu'on peut venir utiliser
avec ses sons apple pencil de deuxième
génération alors là c'est tout de suite
beaucoup moins grand public que ce qu'on
peut retrouver au niveau du magic qui
bordent sur les usages puisque tout le
monde ne pas vouloir prendre un appel
pencil pour venir dessiner écrire
pronote là on est quand même dans un
usage qui est beaucoup plus nicher par
contre il connaît très bien la très
mauvaise écriture donc ça c'est bien
vous avez une caméra à l'arrière
elle vous servira plus pas pour faire
des photos en famille quoique allez
savoir mais pour moi non l'appareil
photo principale ça va être votre
smartphone
ici vous allez utiliser pour un usage un
peu plus professionnel tandis que votre
caméra de celle ci elle vous servira
probablement pour du télétravail pour la
visioconférence pour communiquer avec
des amis c'est l'intérêt il ya une vraie
différence entre ces deux caméras les
caméra arrière et la caméra avant on n'a
pas à voir ici la meilleure qualité mais
une fois de plus pour télétravailler
pour communiquer ça fera très bien à
faire et si vous voulez protéger votre
ipad mais voulait pas mettre une petite
fortune dans un magic qui bordent eh
bien vous avez cette solution là c'est
le smartphone you d'apple qui va venir
vous le protéger et qui est vraiment
extrêmement bien vous positionnez votre
ipad c'est aimante et qui a très très
bien et ensuite vous venez le faire mais
vous le protéger c'est très pratique
ensuite à l'arrière vous prenez vous
retournez vous positionnez ça comme ça
ça vous sert de petit chevalet pour
venir le cal est très facilement pour
669 euros apple les paragraphes et vous
propose les dernières technologies et
notamment du wifi 6 wifi si ce qu'on
retrouve depuis plus d'un an déjà dans
les iphone
on l'a notamment ici dans cet ipad r
c'est très bien au style padar mais je
trouve vraiment bien mais peut-être
n'est-il pas destiné à vous peut-être
est-il fait pour vous ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de vos usages et de ce que
vous m'avez marqué dès le début de cette
vidéo en bas en commentaire alors on va
revenir à pau là dessus parce que c'est
la clé qui nous permettra de savoir si
ce produit fait pour vous ou pas si
comme moi vous êtes dans un usage plutôt
multimédia divertissement c'est
peut-être pas l'ipad qui vous font part
à l'ipad 8 dans quelques jours c'est
peut-être celui là qu'il vous faut si
vous êtes sur un usage grand public sort
de la petite
l'activité que vous gérez vos comptes
vous gérez vos e-mails vous l'utilisez
pour pouvoir travailler également pour
pouvoir collaborer que le magic qui
borde a vraiment un sens pour vous pour
moi il recense pour tout le monde si
c'est juste pour le multimédia
non mais si c'est en dehors du
multimédia pour venir travailler le
magic qui bordent pour moi il est
indispensable donc à ce moment là l'ipad
r et probablement fait pour vous mais si
maintenant vous voulez aller encore plus
loin au niveau des usages si vous êtes
infographiste si vous êtes dessinateur
si vous avez besoin tout en de ce
produit là et vous voulez ce qui a mieux
en terme de performance pour moi on ira
sur l'ipad pro on peut se dire
effectivement avec l'ipad r on peut
utiliser son style et je suis d'accord
mais peut-être pour commencer à
s'initier au stylet mais si vous êtes
vraiment un professionnel il faut aller
sur l'ipad pro parce que vous irez
beaucoup plus loin dans l'expérience
grâce à l'écran avec le pro motion aux
120 hertz ce sera beaucoup plus agréable
beaucoup plus fluide une meilleure
expérience donc à ce moment là on va
vraiment aller vers l'ipad products ipad
r il est vraiment bien c'est un produit
grand public il est plus grand public
que ne l'est l'ipad pro bien évidemment
mais il coûte un certain prix et les
contrats certains prix encore plus si
vous venez lui rajouter le magic qui
bordent qui pour moi est un accessoire
quasiment indispensable et qui coûte
quand même très cher 339 euros seulement
le magic qui bordent par contre une fois
vous l'aurez il a vraiment venir
emmenez votre ipad r dans une toute
autre catégorie dans un produit de
bureautique familiale vous allez pouvoir
faire beaucoup plus de choses parce que
si vous prenez votre ipad r et vous
prenez votre magic qui bordent vous êtes
à 1000 euros
à quelque chose près ça coûte cher très
cher mais par contre l'expérience et la
voilà ce que j'avais à vous dire
aujourd'hui sans cet ipad r pour moi il
est bien pour un usage grand public pour
de la polyvalence pour la bureautique
devant vous ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire est ce qu'il vous
convainc pas du tout est-ce qu'il est
fait pour vous est-ce que vous êtes plus
team est pas de trop ou alors tim ipad r
volant l'ipad 2 8e génération
on en parle dans quelques jours vous
marrer tous à hambach commentaires et à
très bientôt beaucoup d'amour ou prenez
soin de vous ciao
trois mineurs le
amis lecteurs
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]